my name is Ryan Jewell I am asada and CW
21 certified watchmaker working in New
York City today we're gonna break apart
these two watches made by carpenter
watches the one on the Left m15 it has a
Japanese movement in it the one on the
right m2s has a movement made in
Switzerland the carpenter watches with
the Swiss movement in it is eight
hundred and twenty five dollars and the
Japanese movement retails for five
hundred and ninety five dollars I am
putting on what we call finger cots the
acids in your skin will actually
permanently etch into the plating and
finish you always want to have a tool or
something between you and the movement
to get started obviously you are going
to want to remove the straps to do that
you first want to use your spring bar
tool spring bars are the two metal bars
that attach the strap to the case next
we need to remove the case back the case
back is normally incredibly tight I kind
of loosened it just a tiny bit before we
got started so I can open it with my
fingers I'm gonna remove the oscillating
wait the moving Halfmoon that will allow
for automatic winding the Swiss watch
can operate as a manual wound watch or
as an automatic watch the automatic
winding system is modular as opposed to
integrated right now I'm removing the
screws of the casing clamps for the
movement ring the movement ring sits
inside the case and keeps the movement
nice and centered you typically will
find these in watches where the movement
is somewhat smaller than the diameter of
the dials so it kind of fills it out
keeps it centered and secures it in
there
right now I'm removing the movement ring
and removing the stem in the crown
that's what you use to wind the watch if
you're manually winding it since the
stem goes into the movement you have to
pull that out before you remove the
movement from the case with the
automatic winding watch you wear it
every single day you typically never
need to wind it but with the manual wind
watch it doesn't have that automatic
winding mechanism so you typically have
to wind it I normally recommend once a
day setting the case aside and the
movement is now fully exposed I'm gonna
put the crown in the stem back in to be
able to move the hands in order to get
them in a good position to remove them
later on if I need to hold the movement
I can hold it by the crown as well to
kind of move it around I typically like
to put the hands at 12 o'clock to remove
them use a piece of plastic to keep
everything secure and you do it very
gently with the Lummi on certain hands
it can scratch the other hand so you
have to be very gentle you can't just
pry them up very fast otherwise you
could possibly scratch the hands or
cause damage to the hub of the hands now
that the hands are free from the posts
I'm removing them with a pair of brass
tweezers and setting them gently in the
parts tray I use brass and then the
other pair is made out of nickel because
they are both softer metals than steel
and so there's a chance that they'll do
less damage to any anything that you
touch loosening the two dial foot screws
I was able to easily just pull the dial
off from the movement and now the
movement is completely separate and I
can put it in the movement holder to
start this assembly the movement holder
will keep the movement flat there's
little pivots and things that are
sticking out that you don't want sitting
down on the table and if you tried to
work on them without something keeping
it flat then it would be very difficult
and probably cause damage with the Meo
de 821 a the Japanese movement you need
to start on the calendar side the dial
side of the watch but the Swiss movement
you want to start on the watchmakers
side the bridge side right now I'm
removing the plate that's holding down
the date ring kind of secures the date
ring and a lot of the calendar functions
down on the movement
everything will be held down by a series
of screws typically you want to loosen
all the screws and then go and grab them
all reason for that being is it's faster
and more efficient than setting down
your tool every time you loosen one
screw picking up another tool putting
the screw way then going back and forth
the thing that people really like about
watchmaking is that it's kind of the
incorporation of art and science it is a
craft and there is creativity involved
but then there's also times where
they're very strict guidelines that you
have to follow the date jumper spring
basically keeps the date in a certain
position and when the date wheel comes
around to move to the next date and make
sure that it holds it in place to where
it's centered in the window for the date
that is the date jumper spring now I
will be removing the date disc and this
is simply the little disk that has all
of the days of the month on it has teeth
so you can go from date to date working
with the jumper to keep it centered an
imposition the hour wheel is the wheel
that the hour hand is mounted directly
onto and so it has a rotational speed of
one full rotation every 12 hours I was
working in non-for-profit arts art house
cinemas film festivals art museums and I
had about every cool job you could have
in that field and I loved art but I
didn't like the day-to-day work and so I
decided I was going to quit and I
realized that every day when I went home
I wanted to do something with my hands
restoring antique furniture or taking
things apart and seeing how it works in
putting it back together and so I looked
into a few different things watchmaking
ended up being the one that not only was
the most interesting but actually there
is the greatest need this is the
intermediate date wheel that's part of
the Train which moves from the hour
wheel to the date wheel
the jumper is what locks it into
position one position to position three
first position for winding second
position for the quick change of the
date third position would be pulling the
crown all the way out that's for setting
the time the part is on a post the
movements never been taken apart and
I've never worked on this move before so
sometimes you kind of have to know the
right way to go it apart to remove it
otherwise your tips of your tweezers
which are very small will just kind of
slip right off some parts are a little
harder to get off the others this is the
setting leverage spring here I'm
removing the yoke the yoke interacts
with the sliding pinion and it slides
back and forth on the stem to either put
it into a whining position or put it
into time setting position and this is a
little plate that holds down the
intermediate setting wheel and the
minute we lit basically just keeps
everything nice and secure and in place
this is the minute wheel this engages
with the Canon pinion and it bridges the
gap between the minute hand basically in
the hour hand this is the intermediate
setting wheel it basically just kind of
transfers the power from the sliding
pinion to the minute we land the can
opinion this is a cannon pinion and this
friction fits on to your Center wheel
this is what you are actually pushing
the minute hand on to and in so it
rotates one time and it engages with the
minute we land the hour wheel that we
have just removed and here I'm removing
the date wheel date wheel is what
actually tells the calendar when to jump
when it's at midnight one key difference
from the Japanese movement on the Swiss
movement this part is actually made out
of plastic in the Japanese movement
which you will not find any plastic
parts of the solisten
this is the stripped-down dial side of
the main plate we're gonna have to flip
it over now and disassemble the bridge
side or the watchmaker side as it's also
referred to this is the side where the
magic happens for the watchmaker this is
where we're doing the majority of our
work all the adjustments and stuff that
we have to do in a typical service
normally happen on this side of the
movement you'll find your power source
here the barrel and the mainspring the
gear train is here the balance the hair
spring all the parts that really make
the watch tell time all happen on this
side of the movement the first thing
that I'm going to be removing is the
balance bridge with balance attached it
all comes out as one part even though
they're different components that is
what they call the beating heart of the
watch the balance with the hair spring
and that is attached to the balance
bridge with a stud so that's the thing
that's spinning back and forth the hair
spring kind of expanding in and out
regulating your time this is the one
bridge on the Munim movement they call
it the barrel bridge that's what my Oda
calls it with a lot of other movements
including the Swiss movement you'll
actually have a series of bridges you'll
have a barrel bridge you'll have a
separate bridge that's covering the gear
train and then you'll have a module that
sits on top of all of that for the
automatic module for the Swiss movement
with this movement the automatic
components are actually underneath this
bridge with everything else so once you
remove this bridge nothing will work I
just want to give you a shot of the
watch with the bridge removed and this
will show you the gear train the barrel
the automatic components all of it now
I'm gonna start removing the smaller
individual components underneath
starting with the pallet fork that is
held down by the pallet fork bridge so
I'll remove that first and then remove
the pallet fork which is part of the
escapement the escapement is basically
designed to allow the power to be
released in very small measured
incremental bursts and this little
impulse a jewel that's friction fit onto
the bottom of the balance wheel and send
it off into one direction that
mainspring once it reaches its max the
spring will let it go the spring will
pull it back towards that pallet for and
the pallet fork will impulse it the
other way
and so it keeps getting pulled back into
that pallet fork back and forth and
that's how the watch keeps running this
is the pallet fork which is one of my
favorite parts and a watch it has two
jewels that can be depth by hundredths
of millimeters which can drastically
change the way that a watch runs it
basically is kind of what makes
everything work in a watch it's what's
impulsiveness odda Khalil etting out the
power that you've been winding up in in
the barrel it's kind of just where
everything comes to a head this is
called the escape wheel and it is the
beginning of the escapement and the end
of the gear train this is called the
fourth wheel this is now when we're
getting into the gear train the gear
train is going to be your series of
wheels that transfers the power from the
barrel and the mainspring to the
escapement as well as dividing the time
and here I'm removing the third wheel
this is an intermediate automatic wheel
now I'm removing what I would call the
reverser and this is actually part of
the automatic winding this is part of
the gearing that goes from the
oscillating weight to the barrel to wind
the watch with the motion of your wrist
and this is the barrel or the barrel
complete it's actually comprised of four
different parts which would be the
barrel drum the barrel cap the barrel
Arbor and the mainspring the barrel is
the power source for the watch and now
I'm going to disassemble the barrel and
show you the mainspring which is
basically pent up in there kind of like
a snake in a can so you got to keep it
all nice and closed or it'll explode out
everywhere
your winding up this mainspring inside
the barrel around that Arbor very
tightly obviously like any spring it
wants to expand it wants to unwind and
that motion of wanting to expand is what
causes the barrel to turn that barrel
turning is then sent into the gear train
which is transferring the power dividing
the time
every time you service a watch you
normally want to open the barrel and
replace the mainspring you want to give
them a new mainspring every time you
service to watch they come pre coiled
and you can just kind of insert them
into the barrel and push them out of
their little polder this is the
mainspring in a relaxed state inside the
barrel drum I'm just getting the tip of
the the mainspring out and now I'm
basically uncoiling it one coil at a
time so it doesn't pop out and injure
somebody once in watchmaking school I
wasn't so careful and it popped out and
smacked me right in the eyeball and it
was not very comfortable and that is the
mainspring that is what stores and
distributes all of the power that you
build up either by winding it by hand or
with the motion of your wrist and the
automatic mechanism in all mechanical
watches that you find today they have
what they call rubies or jewels they're
actually a synthetic corundum a lot of
people think that the jewels are
precious which is why the watch is
expensive the truth of the matter is
they only exist for friction reduction
there are nine on the Mohs hardness
scale the only thing harder than that
would be a diamond which is a ten and so
they take a very very high polish and
they are very strong and and so where
you'll find jewels is anywhere that
you'll find friction and the goal is
with the the hard polished surface of
the jewel and lubrication that's used in
watches the friction is reduced so much
that you're getting the most amount of
power through the gear train without
losing any of that power due to friction
this is a bridge that's holding down a
center wheel typically the center wheel
will rotate one time per hour and the
cannon pin you'll be affixed to the
underside of it and that's where you'll
mount your minute hand as the wheel
rotates once per hour your minute hand
is rotating one time per hour as well
this is the second pinion this is driven
indirectly off of the gear train if you
bump your wrist or something you'll
actually see a second hand kind of
stutter a little bit due to the slop in
the gears and the indirect drive of the
second hand and the Swiss movement it's
a direct drive of the second hand and so
you don't get that kind of bumping and
now I've removed the center wheel when
you're disassembling movements one thing
that I always keep in the back of my
mind is that in a lot of cases Watch
Company will develop something and
patent something and so other watch
companies have to figure out how to try
to do the same thing by creating a
totally new way of doing it and a lot of
times you'll find some very creative and
frankly inefficient way is to do the
same thing but that's all they can do
because the other more efficient way is
patented the basic design of how a watch
works really hasn't changed a whole lot
within the past two or three hundred
years the main advancements that have
been made have all been in the materials
that are used this is the click spring
now I'm going to remove the crown and
stem again as the disassembly of this
movement is almost complete and that
will allow us to basically strip it all
down put it all in the ultrasonic
cleaner to clean the movement this is
your sliding pinion Yoda the Japanese
movement does it slightly differently
than what I'm used to with a lot of
Swiss movements and so the sliding
pinion and winding pinion kind of are
smushed together in this one as to where
in a lot of other movements there are
two separate parts now we've completely
disassembled the Japanese movement and
all that we're left with is the main
plate this is a completely disassembled
Miata 8:21 a so now we're moving on to
the Swiss movement the Swiss movement
actually does a lot of the same things
in fewer parts the watchmakers side of
the movement with
the automatic module still attached I
can remove that whole thing and you'll
still have a functioning movement and
one of the big differences between the
Japanese and the Swiss movement is that
this movement has bi-directional
automatic winding which means either way
that the oscillating weight moves it
will wind the watch the Japanese
movement only winds in one way the other
way it just kind of spins freely without
doing much of anything
right now I'm loosening the screws on
the automatic bridge which is its own
separate bridge unlike the Japanese
movement it's going to have an upper
bridge which you see on the top and a
lower bridge which keeps all of the
wheels of the automatic winding system
in one place it's all part of one module
I'm going to go ahead and set that down
and disassemble the automatic module
Swiss has long been considered the
preeminent watch making place and it is
a place where the majority of fine
watchmaking happens in the world today
funnily enough actually America I used
to carry that mantle back in the pocket
watch days when it came to standardized
mass production America made some of the
finest movements that existed with
companies like Hamilton wall from Elgin
but those obviously all went out of
business in the 1960s and 70s but
Switzerland has just got a long
tradition of watchmaking and so while
Japan isn't necessarily known for their
watch making companies like Seiko
especially with their Grande Seiko Lian
have really been trying to kind of give
the Swiss a run for their money the way
that the bi-directional winding works is
in this one there are two reversers and
the other one there is only one reverser
the reverser allows it's kind of a
ratcheting system where if it turns one
way it allows it to slip and if it turns
the other way it kind of forces that
power down to the ratchet wheel winding
the watch since this one has two
reversers one of the wheels is always
going to be locked and winding the other
wheel is going to be slipping and
depending on which way the oscillating
weight turns it changes which one is
slipping and which one is locked and
here we've fully disassembled the
automatic module so now we're going to
disassemble the rest of the watch making
side as you can see the automatic module
has been removed and we've got three
different bridges we've got our balance
bridge which holds the balance wheel
with the hair spring attached to it
we've got the gear train bridge under
which the gear train obviously would be
and the barrel bridge you'll find that
watchmakers are not very creative in
their naming of components now I'm
removing the balance bridge very similar
to what you saw on the Japanese movement
the reason that little wheel is bouncing
around so phonetically is because it's
attached to the hair spring now I'm
removing the fork bridge and the pallet
fork the technical name for this type of
escapement is called the swiss lever
escapement this escapement was actually
invented in the 1750s by a english clock
maker named thomas Mudge and while there
are newer escapements that have been
introduced especially in the 1970s with
George Daniels and the coaxial
escapement and some other ones this is
the type of escapement that you will
find in approximately 95% of the watches
that are on the market today
now I'm removing the gear train bridge
this just holds down the third wheel
fourth wheel and escape wheel on the
Swiss movement as to where there was one
bridge holding everything down on the
Japanese movement these are all the
components that make up the gear train
there's only one wheel I believe on this
movement that you need to remove the
bale bridge before you can get to it but
this secures all of the components of
the gear train which will transmit the
power and divide the time watches and
watchmaking were a very viable trade up
until about the late 1960s early 1970s
and at that point what happened was
watchmakers referred to as the quartz
crisis quartz watches were introduced
into the marketplace they were
exponentially cheaper and they were 300
times more accurate than mechanical
watches so that's great and all for
consumers and everybody bought a quartz
watch but for watchmakers it was
terrible because you get paid to
completely disassemble these intricate
machines and reassemble them clean them
adjust them and it takes some time but
now all of a sudden you have this watch
and all you need is every year to 5 to
pop open the case back pop out the
battery pop in a new one and you're done
every once in a while they'll use
reversed threads that ensures that as
that wheel rotates it's not going to
unscrew your screw and send it flying
out into your movement to cause all
kinds of damage and havoc if anything
it's going to tighten the screw even
further you had a lot of people that
were getting out of the profession
because they said they couldn't make a
living anymore because of quartz watches
they said that watchmaking was a dying
art of course like everything is
cyclical about 20 years ago mechanical
watches started making a big comeback
and really really picked up steam within
the last 15 to 20 which was great for
all the watch companies except for the
fact that there's been two generations
where nobody's been training to be a
watchmaker
now I'm removing the barrel bridge this
holds down the barrel with the
mainspring inside and I believe the
second wheel which is the Great Wheel
this is the barrel and we're going to
disassemble this one as well there's
really no difference between these two
barrels you'll have a barrel Cup a
barrel drum mainspring inside that wraps
around an arbor which the arbor kind of
comes out the top and the bottom and
that's what sits between the bridges and
the turning points of the arbor rarely
when you're sitting there disassembling
a movement and making all these
adjustments to very small pieces are you
pondering the existence of time and how
it relates to you but more importantly
it's kind of a special thing to know
that the work that you've done
throughout the day is preserving pieces
that people are going to pass down from
father to son for generations that are
gonna be collected and cherished and the
people will kind of where as something
that is a reflection of themselves it's
how they express themselves by the
watches they choose I've actually never
worn an electronic watch and that's
really for the simple fact that I feel
like I'm already kind of attached to my
phone enough as it is I don't really
want to be any more available than I am
with with my cell phone and so having a
watch that just tells me what time it is
and has kind of a link to history and
the way things always kind of run is
something that appeals to me this is the
Great Wheel if it were in the center it
would be called the center wheel but
it's not in the center so it's called
the Great Wheel the Swiss has a hacking
mechanism and the Japanese movement does
not when you pull out the crown it's
basically a very small l-shaped spring
that will be pushed into the balance
that will stop the balance from spinning
back and forth therefore stopping the
time this is the watchmaker side of the
bridge side that has been completely
stripped of parts there's very little in
the difference between and the Japanese
movement and the Swiss
movement on the dial side of the watch
you're going to have a setting mechanism
you're going to have a setting lever and
an hour wheel and a minute wheel a date
wheel that tells the calendar when jump
a setting lever jumper but the design on
how those components work is gonna be
the big difference this is the hour
wheel this is what the hour hand is
mounted on this is the intermediate date
wheel I believe the Swiss movement the
setting mechanism is a lot less
dependent upon these really tiny little
annoying Springs I have no idea what
they are it seems like there's a lot of
stuff going on in the Japanese movement
as to where the Swiss movement is pretty
simple of a mass-produced watch the
highest that they have is a 36,000 beat
watch that was made famous mostly by
Seiko and zenith with the el primero
which was a 36,000 beat chronograph
there are some really boutique ii like
one-of-a-kind watches that run at really
crazy speeds 50 60,000 vibrations per
hour with the difference between
something small like even 28,800 220
1600 or even the slower beat which is
18,000 which you'll find with old pocket
watches typically run at 18-thousand
vibrations per hour you're not gonna see
a big change in price based on that
alone
the date disc the Japanese one is made
of plastic the other is brass this is
the date wheel and as you can see the
Swiss movement is made of brass and has
a spring-loaded finger so literally the
clicking over of the date might be a
little bit more quick in the Swiss
moment than you would in the Japanese
movement the rest of these components
are very similar in the way that they
work together and what they do in
addition to the vibrations per hour
there are some differences that you will
not see even if you're looking at the
gearing one of those would be the power
reserve the power reserve means that if
you wind the watch up to full wind how
long will it run before you have to wind
it up again because it's run out of
juice on the Miata movement the Japanese
movement it has an advertised power
reserve of 45 hours which means that
full wind it'll run for almost two days
before it runs out of power
the Swiss movement the Edda movement has
a power reserve of 40 hours so not a
huge difference but a 5 hour difference
between the two while they say it's an
advertised power reserve that's normally
kind of low-balling it they like to
under promise and over deliver in that
regard
and so typically it'll run longer than
that they advertise basically kind of
lower expectations and this is normally
determined by the length of the
mainspring the size of the barrel and a
lot of other factors will kind of
determine how long a watch will run
before needs to be wound up again
this is the fully disassembled etta
movement the 2824 from the carpenter
into s and finally here the two
completely disassembled movements side
by side
[Music]
station this is wired how do you
[Applause]
[Music]